it is a full-scale war that many experts
just didn't believe russia would start
president vladimir putin in one fell
swoop demonstrated his country's
military might and instantly isolated
russia from much of the world like a lot
of people we
had concluded that a full-scale invasion
of ukraine
was
was irrational this former canadian
ambassador to russia says the costs are
too great retaliation on russians
banking travel and economy and the
lasting harm to the country's stature
the array of
sanctions will increasingly i think
isolate them as something of a pariah
state internationally at a minimum then
putin needs a swift military victory
it's pretty clear that he wants the
whole country it looks like occupation
and annexation are the objectives but in
recent years ukraine has built up its
military and its resolve ukrainians seem
prepared for a prolonged conflict with
ongoing guerrilla tactics if necessary
the ukrainian government will want to
put as much
resistance as they can to make the costs
of invasion as high as possible why
would putin risk it russia's neighbor
does not threaten it militarily but it's
hard to ignore that ukraine is becoming
a model of progress right next door to
russia's authoritarianism every day
ukraine is becoming a bit more
democratic a bit more prosperous so this
is very much about
undoing a possible um a possible
alternative that is becoming a real
existential threat
to him and his kleptocratic regime
there's already discontent among
russians tennis star andre rublev wrote
no war please on a tv camera lens and
remember how popular alexander ovechkin
was with vladimir putin maybe not after
ovi sent out this message others are
willing to be arrested for protesting
and the war has only just begun russians
will not be happy with body bags of
their sons coming back to russia
so i i don't think this will be a
popular war experts didn't see how war
could advance russia's interests and
believe vladimir putin may realize that
soon enough eric sorensen global news
toronto